TODAY MARKS TWO YEARS SINCE THE ATTACK
ON THE SEAT OF AMERICA'S
DEMOCRACY WHEN PRO-TRUMP RIOTERS
STORMED THE CAPITOL OF DONALD
TRUMP'S 2020 ELECTION LOSS TO
JOE BIDEN.
NOW THE ESTATE OF BRIAN SICKNICK
IS SUING THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
HERE WITH THE DETAILS IS PAULA
REED.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, WHAT ADO YU
KNOW?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE GETTING NEWS ABOUT SPECIAL
COUNSEL JACK SMITH WE'VE LEARNED
HE RECENTLY RETURNED TO THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HAD BEEN WORKING ABROAD
FOLLOWING A BIKE ACCIDENT AND
NOW HE'S BACK HE'S STAFFING UP.
HE'S GOING TO NEED ALL THE HELP
HE CAN GET BECAUSE WE LEARNED HE
HAS A MOUNTAIN OF NEW EVIDENCE
TO SIFT THROUGH AS HE DECIDES
WHETHER THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
HIS ASSOCIATES SHOULD BE CHARGED
FOR JANUARY 6th.
>> WE CANNOT AFFORD TO BRUSH
POLITICAL VIOLENCE UNDER THE RUG
OR TURNED A BLIND EYE WHEN
OTHERS ENCOURAGE IT.
>> Reporter: WHILE PRESIDENT
BIDEN COMMEMORATES THE SECOND
ANNIVERSARY OF THE JANUARY 6th
CAPITOL ATTACK BY PRESENTING
MEDALS TO MICHAEL FANONE AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
WHO RESPONDED THAT DAY, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES THE
BIGGEST CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
IN ITS HISTORY.
ALREADY MORE THAN 950 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR THEIR
ALLEGED PARTICIPATION IN THE
DEADLY RIOT.
ROUGHLY HALF HAVE PLEADED GUILTY
AND 40 HAVE BEEN CONVICTED AT
TRIAL.
JUST ONE HAS BEEN ACQUITTED.
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE THAT
ALSO INVESTIGATED JANUARY 6th
BELIEVES THAT PROSECUTORS SHOULD
CHARGE FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS ASSOCIATES AS WELL.
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
KEY ORGANIZERS AND MOVERS OF
THIS ATTACK DON'T ESCAPE THE
SCRUTINY OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
>> Reporter: THAT DECISION IS
NOW UP TO SPECIAL COUNSEL JACK
SMITH.
APPOINTED TO OVERSEE THE
INVESTIGATION AND EFFORTS BY
TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES TO OVERTURN
THE RESULTS OF THE 2020
ELECTION.
>> BASED ON RECENT DEVELOPMENTS,
INCLUDING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
NEXT ELECTION AND THE SITTING
PRESIDENT'S STATED INTENTION TO
BE A CANDIDATE AS WELL, I HAVE
CON INCLUDED THAT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Reporter: ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND PROMISED SMITH'S
APPOINTMENT WOULDN'T DELAY THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> HE PROMISED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN HIS OWN STATEMENT THAT
THERE WOULD BE NO PAUSE OR
HICCUP IN HIS WORK.
>> Reporter: BUT SMITH IS STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF PUTTING
TOGETHER HIS TEAM.
BRINGING ON TWO LONG-TIME
ASSOCIATES WHO SPECIALIZE IN
PUBLIC CORRUPTION CASES, A
SOURCE TELLS CNN.
SMITH ALSO MUST COMB THROUGH A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE,
INCLUDING WHAT THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE RECENTLY TURNED OVER
AND DISCOVERY COLLECTED FROM
LAWYERS FROM TRUMP ALLIES LATE
LAST YEAR, SOME OF WHICH HASN'T
BEEN OPENED YET ACCORDING TO
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE PROBE.
SMITH HIMSELF FIRED OFF A ROUND
OF SUBPOENAS TO OFFICIALS IN
SEVEN KEY BATTLEGROUND STATES
AND RECEIVED A TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS AND THIS VOICE MAIL
FROM SOMEONE CLAIMING TO WORK
FOR TRUMP'S POST ELECTION LEGAL
TEAM.
>> I'M A LAWYER WITH RUDY
GIULIANI'S TEAM WORKING FOR THE
PRESIDENT, AND WE NEED ACCESS TO
SOME DOMINION MACHINES WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND MAY BE SOMETHING YOU
CAN HELP US WITH.
>> REPORTER: FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON TRUMP'S
STATE OF MIND AFTER THE 2020
ELECTION BUT IN AN INTERVIEW
WITH CNN, TRUMP'S LAWYER SAID
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED, AT LEAST
ABOUT THE EVIDENCE GATHERED BY
THE COMMITTEE.
>> THEY'VE OUTLINED A FEW
CHARGES HERE, ALL OF WHICH ARE
COMPLETELY LEGALLY INSUFFICIENT.
SO YEAH, WE KIND OF LOOK AT IT
AS, IT'S POLITICAL NOISE BUT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY EFFECT AS OF
RIGHT NOW ON OUR DEFENSE.
>> Reporter: THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE RAN INTO OBSTACLES
WITH KEY WITNESSES LIKE MARK
MEADOWS BUT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS ADDITIONAL TOOLS
LIKE GOING TO COURT TO COMPEL
THE WITNESSES TO COOPERATE.
BUT THERE IS CONCERN THIS COULD
GO TOO FAR INTO THE ELECTION
CYCLE.
SO SMITH IS UNDER PRESSURE TO
MOVE THIS ALONG AND MAEZ MAKE
THESE DECISIONS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.